[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody good morning it's
Thursday and you know that means early
access ps4 Cod beta okay sorry I'm
Reaper I had already had my few cups of
coffee you know how it is video prayers
here Ritchie is joining morning y'all
and for those fellow ps4 players out
there the call of duty modern warfare
multiplayer beta is live it will be live
early access for the next few days
before everyone else gets their hands on
it uh and yeah let us know how it
sounded how it's looking are we we doing
good are we ready to go I'm about to lay
out some band hammers in the chat freeze
spammers good lord
yeah take a timeout what's a crime
welcome to everybody see ya Bob Jones
okay it's there's never too much dancing
alright but yes here we are we're just
gonna jump right into it because why not
let's go multiplayer Jay said good
evening well wherever you're located
good evening to you as well thanks for
joining us um
oh I'm the party leader hey hey let's do
it
UK in the house joining us J welcome
loud and clear says the Thompson yet
just as in Jason's how do I close a chat
you only could fullscreen the stream you
can do that yeah you go in theater mode
and it kind of pushes it below you
really want to block the chat what's up
Freddie
walking to the stream Kevin Lewis says
what's poppin everyone good morning yeah
play TDM I would if I had it my way it's
not throwing random games like
domination maybe some TDM chill bill
love you guys we love you do man thanks
for joining us yeah oh yeah
the see okay good luck
yes quad good luck have fun ready being
yelled at so many Canadian so you're
stuck with the regular loadouts
yeah like a I'm gonna watch the replay
cuz that oh I'm dying
it's breathe just go
you got a pre-order that's right this
first weekend I just launched this
morning but we've had a few games in
before stream it's not hardcore but yeah
now see the personal UAV or the higher
tier unlock for the UAV for everyone I
like you know I haven't really have even
paid attention to it don't shoot hard to
jump into or not at the beginning yeah
we try to retain that same sniper
trying I love that run
yeah but you're assuming that it takes
away here I believe the 80s faster I
just got so yeah open every door let's
go okay and that did not pay off
right a stick we can lower the gun boy
free safety crime I'd died for that me
shoot I probably would he died anyway
why I'm not a Dom player I rushed too
much and my KD is usually dead center
but not like not during domination yeah
how we sounding guys I feel like the
biggest things for me and I start
playing games getting used to the maps
my running into dead-end rooms and stuff
like oh no me too and now there are
doors that kind of break that a little
bit like it's not it's not always a dead
end and sometimes there's just an option
to open the door which is nice someone
stinks over here I walked into like a
green cloud and I got you're talking
about my gameplay all the way then they
just died
there's still a lot of stuff I haven't
really seen like whatever that sting
grenade was or something
I just tilt some lemons that's good for
dumb I used it earlier this morning
okay everyone's trying to cap you just
smoke them out with that Klopp said that
his is still downloading oh yeah it's a
big file there he is
it is pretty big for a beta for sure
even though the 2v2 alpha is actually
pretty big - yeah it was amazingly go
for beat I got flash
dad says turn on inverted why honestly I
feel like I've only ever met a handful
of people who actually played inverted
same it's pretty uncommon oh I've got
Rockets but great I think it takes three
rockets to take down the top Oh waiting
to get a chance all right let's try that
out
crap I don't want to run up
Wow I couldn't even aim at it the recoil
definitely takes some getting used to
yeah it's also a little different too
I mean what's on the most recent
like when I was I played a bunch of
World War two recently and in domination
if you start capping the plane and then
you walk off the pole it doesn't really
save that progress you made on the meter
it doesn't but it does which is yeah it
kind of hangs out for just a second
Oh way to end the triple kiddo I know
Brandon says get to the chocolate we're
trying its cabin missile we're good
do I have maybe Jimmy will help you with
recoil I've actually been using single
fire on this football whatever using
hell um whatever that first one is our
5.56 please and ian's why is the picture
so dry
well they do let you choose obviously
like we're doing everything the
brightness I've noticed on some of the
stages like the one that's kind of in I
don't know rocky desert or something
like that
that'd be there certain caves and stuff
that you can't really see him from
certain angles so I would probably
recommend turning up the brightness as
much as you can
together old wood they didn't get him
hey chat what do you think about the
respawn camera now it shows the whole
map and then zooms you in on to your
location we're to rub it in with that
kill the match was over and I got killed
anyway getting killed probably yeah do
you need plus for this beta oh that's a
good question has already had plus so I
didn't I don't believe so run into any
issues the beta is free if he's
pre-ordered Modern Warfare already and
for I think the next like today tomorrow
and Saturday only ps4 players who
pre-ordered can play this early so far
so crime says he's ok with Kim yeah I
think it's cool because you can kind of
see where everyone is on the map for a
split second which is nice Anthony says
why does every con need to have
SuperSpeed gameplay I don't necessarily
think that it has to you I feel like
this might just be us I kind of feel
like this is a little slower oh I can
change my II know I can change my
classes now and I didn't even do it
here's the cave map there's a daytime
version and then there's a nighttime
verse whom I haven't played on the
nighttime version yet actually me either
I think I mean though with the mp5 looks
good
I haven't had the greatest of luck on
this math to be honest but we're
starting from the beginning it is TDM
sweet so so far every time I played on
this map it's been TDM so I don't know
if they have certain downside to certain
game modes possible but because based on
the sizes the gut oh my goodness I
somehow got a triple kill we're alive
nice I'm scared I don't want to be in
this game
got him with a grenade I don't see
anybody outside are you still still
alive after that triple kill I get these
streaks you know it's scary in these
toys do you're right yep love these cave
Oh No how are the main workers I'm alive
you got it this is so far just barely
navigating the menus it's been it's been
nice it's been easy I already set up a
custom loadout with no problems picked
an operator it's so far it's pretty easy
which is good
I don't think I should be using the
advantage there are longer lines of
sight than I thought in this cane oh boy
oh boy and I got him ooh I just busted
down the door that's another thing in
this game you can open doors and stuff
now which is lots of fun yeah
very tactical oh shoot here we go yeah
probably gonna die I just did your feet
is more important than mine cause it's
on the street it is it is cripes I'm
trying to flank these fools yeah I
wanted to pick another gun you know it's
like okay emesis she still like bullets
somehow I still have no see if I can get
anybody with this missile whoo nice
someone didn't get them sorry you're
still alive that says something you
should have the feed I'm trying to get
those chopper and a couple goes away but
you know how it is guy yeah like one go
away hang out a little bit I like that
they put all the call-outs for the maps
up at the top no that was me Oh
damage on ting friendly fire no who's
chasing me three sensitivity that
shouldn't be happening anywhere whoo I'm
still alive not a pretty good spot with
them you waste no enemy territory right
now 100% no well dang almost maybe I
should have deployed my shields I don't
really like using that thing I found
that much you spray it's kind of
[Music]
two of our teammates eaten ad no he died
together Samuel says can't wait to
please no I think I picked the wrong Wes
no biggie
okay remind me to make a classic for
sure you should have that unlocked by
now ooh right meow ah behind me okay oh
well that's that skull was my dead body
I've gotten like four hit markers on
this one guy oh that's so no we do it
he's gone away oh do I know where he is
right yeah he I'm reloading
oh no there was another one I never mind
okay I finally got that guy I found him
track him down
nice meanwhile I'm afraid
Wow well there's two people in there
dang why can't we have full-auto FAMAS
because it was too cheap remember what
it was like when it exists black out
black ops or what was it no model went
for three had a semi-auto I believe are
nothing me out of three round burst I
shoulda got that I'm that was sloppy
okay yeah
back in the fight I saw someone out
there someone else
mm-hmm actually oh boy
should I use that first rent this guy
over here
thanks everyone for tuning in hopefully
you can get your hands on this if you
get a ps4 and pre-order the game all
takes but next weekend even if you
haven't pre-ordered you'll be able to
play for free yeah oh
sloppy someone else is there these can
oh I'm like ducking away like in real
life these cave campers over here oh boy
man I got a cruise missile but this map
see how useful it is whoo they keep
spawning me in the caves too it's it's
so stressful which way the nighttime
version of this here we go bust out my
iPad
hmm they're all inside this stinks
hello from Belgium let's go I don't
wanna be in these caves anymore go
around alright there we go
do I dare look at my score chart no oh
they don't have deaths in oh how kind
they don't they did in domination for
some reason how kind of them yeah let's
just say I got 10 kills that's it nor
these noise definitely positive Katy the
gun sound is pretty good honestly that's
been probably the the thing I've heard
the most so far yeah modern warfare I
agree
looks like Cod's wants Cod wants to
besiege you see that a little bit and
the regen peak now not a bad thing just
taking inspiration yeah the peaking of
yeah oh let me change my write my thing
might think I'm a Jew there okay hello
from California
what up hello from India alright all
over the map thank you everyone for
joining
I haven't even unlocked is gonna been
using the whole time I'll go through the
menu here for Chad to step p CalWORKs
it's a pretty simple so far this is my
current loadout and here are the the
perks I only have two available at the
moment okay okay I haven't unlocked
anything in particularly great but yeah
oh no there's the dollars market hello
from canada and europe and why city
let's go wow everyone in the chat letter
gaana wow you guys great all right let's
see
I made a class but hello from my mom's
house industry I'm actually gonna be in
Detroit a little over Detroit
oh man I got a nice night but we got to
two points already
yeah took a and B I played this map I
think the most so far in the beta how do
you like this map I think so overall -
there's a lot of places where I got like
closed in and like spawn trap this
corner specific but other than that it's
a nice big map so that's why that's what
made me mad it was like how many spawn
trap maps because here we go I'm at a
hello from LA let's go hello from Philly
hello from Alcatraz all over the place
yeah keep shouting it out thanks for
joining us from all over the world
yeah oh no I forgot light in this game
it's not as cool as apex but it's very
tactical but it does things yeah it does
things every character is like an old
man with bad knees though that's so slow
to get up after the slide go back here
you know Cap'n B let's go
like you know all kinds of things
happening how fo Oh No
on the way maybe not I'll distract for a
no Lala we got it
keeping the lead Ryan Lochte's mm yeah
oh we're here
this guy he literally walked into the
street and laid on the floor how dare
you
whoa hello from Delaware hello from
Argentina
wow thank you everyone for joining guy
oh my gosh
oh no cruise missile okay just be
prepared being sloppy y'all let's see if
I can somebody with this freaking
missile decide got it domination is
perfect for the truth is oh yeah they're
behind me maybe I'll get the upper hand
up here good lord
we slide wonder if you just slide so
many times your player will just stop
and go broke - I did the building work
to be fair it had no roof
there's so much shooting I think going
on above me this is scary I have no idea
where those yeah we're dominating all
the Hannah spawn somewhere so far I do
like the a K I think I actually wanted
to try something else so we got here
that's what oh I haven't been using the
a K that's right I've been using that
for I'm gonna go back to the a K see how
it there I just know that could have
been my third watch out over the window
oh okay I took care of it they really in
the smallest blind spot we gotta get you
though what's interesting
oh hello phone from Iran can we oh can
we slide in the game yes you can oh yeah
so it's interesting that you don't
switch sides in this I'm so used to like
after 100 points right inside a good
game or whatever how's your morning
brant a pretty fun okay it's not so
funny anymore cuz I'm totally with that
what great who's shooting me there's
this guy in this building nurse and it's
above the playground and there's like so
many freakin people I just got I know
I've gotten the revenge
hi from India whatever Ajay
no they took the other way Wow time to
slide on in no come on come on pick your
head out oh [ __ ] - they were right hmm
I love get feedback I can't lose this
sweet and ones over there I know it the
others oh I'm not worth it hello from
Korea oh we're getting a request to
please snipe a bit I don't think you oh
yeah I'm the one of the feet you know
what I'll try I stink
and I'll be a lot more cautious but I'll
do it for stream maybe it would have
benefitted me to be a little more
cautious I'm a running gunner there's I
see you got your back got your six
goodbye from Russia thanks for tuning in
whoa someone was here shooting my but
nobody see let's get B with that aim
don't snipe yeah exactly Thank You Simon
I can barely shoot this regular it says
you know I play cod so I can spray and
pray they can be accurate I just pray
oh boy
you're right Simon looking clearly I
shouldn't be sniping I should barely
even be playing actually
cruise missile oh no I need use this
missile for the games
Oh Jake hey it was UAB oh boy
happy birthday do you not our birthday
happy birthday Khan
happy birthday to you we like this try
it Bruce jumping on this map yeah that
is very much
yeah yes we win streak you really can
kill people after victory is announced
or you're lost you can still kill people
it's kind of cool how if spawns been I
would say domination isn't a good place
to like talk about spawn but I think
that team deathmatch one is pretty good
isn't bad yeah there were like one or
two times where I was like okay I got
spawn killed but not often yeah I think
it definitely matters the game type for
sure like if team is really coordinated
it's super hard to avoid getting spawn
trapped in domination use an LMG I got
you next match
we just mute everybody yeah we are
playing on ps4 Pro I saw that in the
chat earlier we are both of us right yes
yes yes sorry I was trying to change my
my perks nobody to the game that's
always it's just cause things you guys
gunfighter this one's for you yeah
either some games it's way too long this
is dope either some games it's way too
long the intermission or it's like not
long enough your first Cod was ghost
Oh Pokemon goes first I don't think I
please map up I love how you can kick
open the door that's great
I've been politely opening them like a
jerk oh yeah oh yeah oh I'll let you me
kicking the door to save your book did
everything's going dark what was crazy
as we had like six teammates over here
and just one bad guy randomly I hope I'm
doing it justice with this LMG I used to
love these because I'm a very I'm very
much a spray-and-pray guy so like this
is for people like me oops just a ton of
bullets okay still exploring the map
here I'm lost
[Laughter]
yeah we're learning it's beta baby shot
that guy in the [ __ ] oh noes wuts kill
someone they quit oh I could handle it
thank you how do you guys feel about the
option to open doors and stuff no
version how do you feel
I mean the dope or nah it's cool to an
extent I think when you kick it open and
forget I remember that somewhere in one
of them so that one of the developers
was saying it makes noise enough noise
to like oh shoot to attract some
attention there's so many people try to
come after me at the zoo I had a double
door and I had to individually close
each door oh really yeah oh yeah hope
this one gets a prop hunt down the road
yeah always I always welcome prop on
it's so silly problem is so fun it's
like when you need a break especially
it's like
it's so funny it's alright I'm rocking
the mp7 nose manual and this bad boys
cheap I use that a lot during the Alpha
it's a pretty tough George will be fun
for scaring people
yeah I get jumpscared popping and
surprise mama this door locked
keep trying to ping like I'm wasting all
my needs
okay I do miss going faster with with a
lighter gun so I might switch it up here
and aim down sights on these guns these
Ellen jeans are ridiculous where is
everybody
yeah I'm having a hard time finding the
action I am on the outskirts
someone found me that's always the can
shoot that cruise missile do I have one
no way I do go Thank You Chad Wow
all this nice outdoor map so the chopper
is really cool actually because you get
to use the chopper as if you were
actually flying inside of it like you
see the cockpit and everything I still
have an unlocked one I'm not that good
and then like if it gets shot down you
can see your pilot like freaking out
trying to regain control of it I hope we
get him Oh command me I'm gonna unload
all right fine I'm over here no don't go
through that door he probably thinks
he's safe sacrifice probably the one
camping him oh that guy was on the roof
maybe I should jump on the roof a little
more chat asks worth the pre-order I
mean that might be able to
I somehow out sit down we see guys and I
was feeling super good about it and then
third guy but I got madness so let's do
this hmm this seems like a good map for
the night
oh that guy was laying down he was
all-pro oh no they have a chopper oh I
see the UAV hmm it was blown out of the
sky something was
no I just walk into someone with martyr
down below me oh no just kidding I
thought it was wow that was crazy
someone threw a need right in the area
and I died right after the timing was
impeccable they planned it still winning
by 20 how am i doing I'm okay I'm
contributing I'll say that probably not
the best that's how it's always been
with Claude and me though that's my
relationship with God but I love to play
nobody ran to you because we both why
shouldn't you pre-order oh you don't
like what you see or if they're not a
cod fan maybe don't or you can if you
want to play this and actually get your
hands on it you had you a pre-order for
this weekend but next weekend you'll be
able to play beginning pre-order so hop
on next weekend or the week after to the
weekend after it'll come to Xbox and PC
going on all mine no we're posted up
here I feel trapped
I'm straight-up catching every single
druid you say rat rat but we're cool no
we're moving out now man lost a homie up
here man drop shotting is still so good
in this game oh you're drought sugar
I don't understand why oh yeah three
words Wow
why the eff didn't they add back the
javelin it's not in the game I didn't
notice that's acceptable Thank You melee
weapons are there son there was like I
still have to throw a knife and that
little that's right
but like hmm I still know that it takes
more than one hit the day they're there
sticking with that random now it shows
the deaths 12 and 7 okay get the high
ground
yeah next game I think I will try that
throwing knives are still a thing
Smitty yes I haven't unlocked him I
don't think let's see if we can edit
loadout
I super really use the mp5 very much
have I unlocked anything else right you
want to back out of like after this
gaming like and like check out the
gunsmith yes yeah let's see about those
throwing knives yo we got the dwight
schroot in the chat can you Tilton is
absolutely correct already done it
plenty of times in the I don't know one
hour and 58 minutes it's been let's go
here we are
Azir kills right something like that yes
the daytime Odeon I saw them played on
the night thing I'm not sure if it's
available for beta well I haven't seen
it yet hmm which way to go we're all
spread out here yes there's someone over
here i flashed him okay I'm gonna go in
for the Salinas hours nope he waited for
the kill
he's still there you got him yeah yeah
good looking out I was the scapegoat up
in the corner cuz he knew he slide
flashed him so he was like the same with
this guy back here
alright I'll try to I'll try to peek
over a wall for you guys to see in check
no time to talk oh the beta is currently
only for people ps4 who have pre-ordered
the game next weekend it'll be available
for everyone on ps4 no strings attached
oh my goodness I will be honest like the
first few games I played I did feel like
it was clunky but now that I've been
playing a little more I'm getting more
used to it I think you'd be a mistake
clunky for more realistic like we're
used to Cod just being this run-and-gun
any bullet to the toe is gonna work type
of you know cod sometimes yeah but it
feels a little more refined a little bit
more like you need a little more effort
I'm so far I'm not saying it feels
clunky to me that's just me I do think I
need to change my sensitivity I do
normally play a little higher so feels a
little sluggish but not clunky I don't
think not to me
I also yeah like I said I always play a
higher sensitivity anyway I haven't
really messed with the settings yet
doing okay I take that back
I just got white wow will it be
available for PC it'll be available for
PC not this weekend not next weekend the
one after I always get smoked on this
map same for Xbox one it'll be available
for y'all
weekends time I wanna unlock ghost
snitching on me oh I always loved
running ghost
or whatever it's called in every game
yeah just love being off the radar
yep played the beta last weekend oh the
Alpha that did you guys like the 2v2
mode saw that where was he he's in the
cave oh I played the breakpoint beta
last weekend yeah we'll see you know no
surveillance for a reason
yeah but also like if you're unsure
about a game just try it out
and don't die in the process this is
this stream I'm whipping it y'all need
some help some motivation for chat
actually nothing can save me
munitions box okay well I saw somebody
loading okay we're all here oh boy we
get some I don't think I have a class
but I'll check it for you friend no you
can change your from Oz oh yeah
salt rifle sniper alright I'll try out
the philosophy with single burst click
Oh semi-auto vs. birth fire okay
semi-auto for you friend let's see how I
do and I'm sorry knit miss once you get
used to the recoil oh it's pretty sharp
huh it's not as bad as as it is
be more mindful since a single shot
crochet there's like I killed me earlier
revenge revenge just feels extra good in
this because I'm always gonna shot in
the butt well he's camping out there
okay
I'm so am i I'm out of here yeah I know
we can't ping Lord right we don't know
call outside he's in cave East carp oh
I'm in outposts that little Hut
he closed the door on me oh my god the
bullets in trying to conserve energy
letting all the cold air out Oh Mike
Texas right so that was a big thing for
us leaving the door open yeah don't
leave it yeah if you got the a/c on No
Deal
whoo okay I cannot semi-auto to save my
life there's a replay prove it cowboy
guns only y'all I can barely function
I'm gonna go back to the good old boy
I'm not a semi-auto boy man I'm barely a
regular for auto what revenge got him
fortunately it's not a spray-and-pray
game anymore yeah I mean I agree I'm not
saying like the fact that I can do that
makes it bad I just don't like makes it
feel like a more refined call of duty
the time to kill is still behind a fast
well I think that brings it back up for
me I'm still spraying dragonflay
spray-and-pray series rifle I was using
the FAMAS no I was using an m4 just now
here we go
that I can handle were you at they see
me okay maybe I can't handle it's on the
other side of the caves
oh well dang it dang it oh we're a
little surrounded I see what they're
shooting from no shootings pissing that
out but that definitely had nothing to
do with me or me take oh my god yeah
nothing to do it little ol hit man Brock
down there five some reason on this map
they don't show the deaths only this one
they know everyone get the bodies on
this yeah
I had high hopes for this map it's fun
but I'm no good at it I gotta get I
gotta like play more I think to learn
all the nooks and crannies cuz I got
body look at that oh there are the
deaths map in the top top left now
there's like a few mental things that
happen to me every time someone's UAV
expires one I think the rounds over cuz
that was always something that happened
around be over head go away or it seems
I feel like I'm in oh you left my part I
did we can play gunsmith I'm sorry you
were making you were in the middle of a
point about the map and the other thing
that happens is it makes me feel like
I'm playing hardcore but I'm not right
yeah except it doesn't take that quickly
to die although if you're me it does
here we go okay what you guys want to
see what I mean
I can't I'm not the best sniper or but
you know pick a gun maybe I'll go
through them here see what you guys
think I don't have any of them most of
them unlocked also to get the level up
so let's start with D I'm gonna go to
the assault rifles got a few of those
who the m13 was unlocked for me okay
intra Sam I'm looking at some of the
sights right and it has pros and cons oh
right and one of the cons of having a
scope is that your ATS is slowed down so
that's what's making it slower is that
you actually have a scope attached
that's right which is interesting
because I don't know is that new I don't
remember that being in any cause that
I've played no sites are usually tweaked
your abs and I don't think oh you know
what that's not sure that's not true a
cogs always did because they're just
okay like you have to look into it more
now they're recognizing that yeah that's
interesting because I always like having
an object but now I kind of feel like I
don't want to use it because
I need the quickness okay successfully
use this saw I'd be impressive using LMG
not against that already have a class
for that I want to try out this other
assault rifle though
here we go the m13 here are the handguns
I don't have many unlocked also but two
of them are out I would always use this
one though this one was a beast in the
Alpha gonna go with the rocket launcher
though I like I like doing air support
this is really interesting
the the gun bench like what each being
does now and it gives you the pros and
cons so there's stuff I would usually
use and every Cod that I don't even want
to put on there now because because it
has negative yeah I don't need anymore
disadvantages okay same a trifle seems a
little low where there ain't yeah four
out of eighty five out of eight kind of
sounds like maybe you like just right on
the marker for me maybe yeah maybe 10
would be nice these look crazy though I
haven't unlocked most of as you most of
them as you can see aperture I'm ready
to get back into it when you are awesome
I just made one class here are the
operators guys there's you can pick them
from different parties coalition or the
allegiance I picked
Charlie here who looks like Sigourney
Weaver and Captain Price at the same
time the rest are unlocked except for
the Diamond Dogs look at this guy give
this guy a monster now yeah here we go
he posed rains I like that name Alice
locked yes there was a bipod on the a K
that's funny huh I didn't unlock that no
but it was there and I was I've just
unlocked some claymores yeah yeah Oleg
you got the little training video see
I've always loved clean wears ooh
syntax alright I'm ready to throw us
back in alright let's do it oh there it
is kill streak select all that should be
playing we're on the west coast so we're
playing on the California server I think
that's there's one in the Bay Area and
then it goes up to Pacific Northwest are
you still here okay good yeah
interesting they've changed some of the
perks from perks to field upgrades
that's right yeah so um dead silence is
a field upgrade now so basically the
field upgrades are kind of like ultimate
abilities I don't know they're not that
ultimate but it takes time for them to
charge up and then you get to you know
stuff like that
cool you can edit the loadouts from the
menu now sick I just saw that it gave me
an option all right let's try this out
currently this is for ps4 only next
weekend
it'll still be for ps4 but the weekend
after that it'll be for everyone else
for this weekend you can only pre-order
if I'm sorry you can only play if you
pre-ordered the game cap and a let's go
someone's over here yeah I saw that's
all that dug that drums it's so good
it's I'm not a good drop shot or maybe
that's why I just don't do it
it's cuz I play on tactical we do right
that's a little different way of light
in mofos back here in our spot where we
were shoot I see one oh that's a
claymore set oh I've got the kill before
I died rip I spawned at sea so well at
least we got a MV and look they spawned
me at sea yeah one guy I window Laurie
says pew pew pew yes all morning
munitions box for my friends that rocket
sound effect sounds like my car's always
open for is very good good luck with you
so far
hey they spawned me at hey let's go it
has probably the least Rico I of noticed
from all the games I've used so far
wrong button and I flashed myself go I
got it who's here
what's this music ed glitching over
there I can barely see him
hatin them I'll probably oh here we go
nope
yes you do that's the requirement here
if I don't die using this message very
sad turn from the wall to do it oh oh
there you go
vs. got a cruise missile inbound
everyone's inside yeah okay I'm just
playing around in the corner over here
let's go back
Oh someone was right there
dang it he was on to me
[Music]
really if I have landed that staying
missile I would've got good effort
though I don't think
yeah I staying taking this back yeah
that's such a buzzkill literally that's
why they call it that yeah I think the
other guy got that buzzkill someone's
photo daniel says greetings from poland
what's up : hey what's up thanks for
tuning in
hopefully you like cod under fire please
okay go away
why is everyone holding hands ooh
someone here mmm not gonna find out I'm
gonna go around critical that you get
different firing options with just about
every gun that I've seen so far yeah not
much of a single fire guy but it's nice
to have the option kind of pick at
people and I'm tip Kristen where the
carbon and Halo is one of my favorites
[Music]
not in my house
you got this 50 hey grab me here I'm
close enough oh no three wait there's no
staircase there oh come on I'm trying to
take B we're behind writing drops
hunting way too good oh he shut the door
in my face and then shot me through it
that was some next-level stress Wow the
guy's already a Call of Duty guy come on
I'll hit the roof on chat try to take
back be trying to win this
oh well I got that guy hmm man we maybe
have some objectives y'all
yeah I tried for B but it's hot right
now I shot someone through a car
oh there you are I think I really love
kicking doors all right you know I'm
gonna go okay someone else is someone
else thought what I was thinking and we
need the cap see get back into this ring
around the Rosie
no ok I gotta move oh wait wait I can't
die right now if I do get the chopper
I'm going to switch to my seat so you
guys can at least like see it yes action
but I get that was lucky that was very I
got to be with my rocket and I came back
getting gunned down to the color Duty
thing yeah I know I haven't blinked in
like 45 minutes there we go
that's the guy who got me last time yeah
all right I've got one too let's go
Thank You Chad for reminding me gamma
UAV up
holy moly
all right we got Bravo yeah we do
I almost died at Bravo thank you oh so
many explosions that was good seafood Oh
rats rats why you know burst shooting
but here I mean I'll do it for you
hey I got you a couch this is not Mardi
Gras I'm dead good lad price would be
proud no not of my gameplay appreciate
you though prices oh my goodness I saw
c-4 on the floor and completely freaked
out I have no idea no there's so many
people here I feel surrounded at all
times can't wait to play the the 20 be
20 yard whatever they think they know
see even higher for the beta oh yeah I
don't get the UAV
[Music]
I always look down on my killstreaks I'm
like oh I have something I'm like oh
it's actually uh oh stop talking cuz
that's me I can't do both I'm just
trying to barely do one okay red asks
for sniper - yeah I'll do it for you to
see what it looks like but uh only for
you chopper gunner oh good lord
oh it's so close it's such a close game
I just noticed right time to use my
muscles
no try to go for that 360 knows we need
to know they're gonna recoil in the
sniper my heart is broken yeah we were
like up that entire game that was we
were back and forth with the end I had
hope I had hope cuz they took all three
though and it just washed us out
I'm very sad yeah I had 36 kills 36 and
15 and we're using my feed I'm right
under you but look at my deaths it's
embarrassing
Michael sent saponin F yeah we lost it
was our first loss of the day real
smooth now we're just slowly walking
through the smoke Bob Jones so close all
this smoke around this is our shame we
have to walk slowly through it and it's
left what we've done I'm gonna play over
here in shame okay you got time for one
more week Monica one more we're creeping
up on 12:30 I mean I'm gonna be playing
those all day I got one thing to do and
then they're gonna be playing for the
rescue I got a cap that's what I call it
yeah I just got a cap you know for work
are you my party hmm I mean I don't know
I mean your brain okay great
Sigourney Weaver front and center let's
go good games there you go oh is this
the nighttime one Hey look crime is
requesting your feed I mean now the only
issue about that is you want to have my
audio you'll savages audio so I want to
swap you sit here
they want your fee the people have
spoken no problem here we go
I mean sure these two but these is Sarah
oh and you're gonna have to plug in your
headphones to that other smell like it's
fine you guys will hear every Richard's
audio but you'll see oh you're cool you
want to switch over to yours there we go
yeah I bet it on Oh camera so big who
did this who did this the police have
been called oh boy where's everyone
oh wow there's I'm using watch me come
through with like my best game and we're
on your feet I know if you start popping
off I'm switching back to your because
honestly I've been getting bodied on
this map every single time me too
among your six oh there's headshot oh
boy how's everyone doing in Chad Kay's
map copy from no well we'll leave that
up to you I can't stay up late oh [ __ ]
maybe I should pay attention huh Chad
you know can't ignore the chat I know
we're sorry Chad we're both in on this
that's why we're just invested sis slide
we're in a deployable cover they found
me bro up their prison yeah this guy's
picking and picking on me I was like I
see gunfire he had the upper hand
already it upper ground okay glad it
Europe we're on your feet a little nasty
crime this plays way differently best
caught every mm-hmm I hear it's all good
and opening the doors louder than a
gunshot go around No
helping you come back because I didn't
want out to chase bad news how's
everyone doing in chatter you guys uh
you guys pre-order you playing this beta
this weekend as I died oh right the
audio is from Maya we're using purchase
de but that's the sacrifice here well
not a sacrifice that's just how the
workaround is for the flank although I
killed that one guys so I'm just
expected nice is there anything I can do
for a hotfix on the audio there here I
mean like we said they are gonna hear
mine as they watch yours but if there's
anything I can do let me know we're up
by 10 good start see you guys when you
put me on their dream nothing exciting
happens ever oh well I'm really glad
they're not seeing my stream them you
can hear me getting flash banging
I went in there hose my missile I beat
them down in the grill
no more panic swiping I guess yeah nope
it takes tuna just like black ops no BX
B's oh man those missiles are cheap even
if you run inside very not be no windows
or no doors and are you done mmm
I'm going for it listening oh I thought
Ike that's me being spoiled by old
cotton someone dying immediately ooh he
was waiting for me god this is my
nightmare yeah I was it was a standstill
between me and some other guy and I
didn't know which way to look to be
honest I heard gunshot came from
everywhere the UAV was freaking me out
you got this down it was oh boy
yeah not a friendly grenade oh god of
gas noise
no I'm doing actually all right I got a
three piece what up look at the he got
stuck trying to open the door don't open
doors that ain't your house all right
stage boo
so much gunfire where's it coming from
I'm too low I do like this map though
people are getting really good at it
really fast I love how it looks shiny
bees city is Oh
I think I was repot Oh brainstorm says
the guns feel so much better on this Cod
so far I agree I don't know I think it
has something to do with the sound
design it really it feels like you know
like chunkier feels good feels solid did
I adjust sensitive II it's on default
I'm playing on default sensitivity right
now do you normally play on oh my lord
no I didn't know no clue full auto here
we go we're still up nothing no thanks
to me this is probably yeah I'm yeah I'm
getting bodied again of course I'm gonna
get back to my desk and play Wallace Lee
yeah but right now brainstorm agrees he
likes the gun sounds they're definitely
you win well look watch this no thanks
to me oh I'm gonna take that away now is
there gonna be my kill really is it I'm
pretty sure on the last one let's go
please I was like whatever I'm rushing
there you go how you get it done good
nice he got the killcam and everything
[Music]
Katie I was like if I didn't go positive
this high five
isn't desert okay that's fair is this on
pc no this is a PS yeah
soon it will be right now we're playing
on ps4 Pro and the only way to play it
is on ps4 Pro and you had to have
pre-ordered the game next weekend if
you're on ps4 you'll be able to play for
free and then the following weekend PC
and Xbox will be able to play for free
as well come on think I got that right
yeah cool
so that just about wraps it up for today
you guys please go play some Call of
Duty because it's out it's happening
yeah and all that pre-order guys that
Ritchie has talked about I'm gonna back
out of this Lobby so we don't get stuck
in another game with or without the
stream yeah we definitely had a ton of
fun you guys we hope you enjoyed it as
well and be sure to tune in every
weekday at 11 a.m. Pacific time for some
game spot love action yeah but until
next time
well see you guys later bye
[Music]